jubilee ocho versos 18 mujeres deciden
quién es la mejor pareja las citas
pueden ser competitivas pero qué pasaría
si fuese un trabajo en equipo
reunimos a 8 mujeres para que salieran
con el mismo
[Música]
hola
hola soy marx tengo 23 años por cierto
son muy bella y si se queda en el centro
de mars se quedarán
si pasan a la izquierda no se quedarán
saldrán del escenario y tomarán un
asiento ahora
es lo más bonito que me ha sucedido
ronda dos charla con cocktail
hola como estan y tu nervioso no te
gusta la atención creo que
[Risas]
si te gusta beber ir decirme a veces
viajo mucho soy modelo me llevan a
lugares para las fotos genial tienes una
expresión de modelo
la verdad es que no tengo lo que hacen
es tomarte la foto mientras hablas y eso
un estilo natural como de la cinta misa
para las audiciones no se puede tener
una camisa nos muestran si queremos ver
lo haré luego de acuerdo no se preocupe
como eres un modelo tiene citas o viajas
muy
viejo mucho aunque me encantaría tener
una ella está aquí
y teniendo sólo tres novias y todas las
relaciones fueron largas de dos años
cuál es tu signo
sawyer significa
dicen que somos simpáticos
también que somos dueños decidiremos por
ti si esto es por eso funciona para hoy
no tengo que decidir hay algo que
quieras en particular describen este
tipo bien no es por ser cliché
físicamente no tengo un tipo bien
aunque hay tres cosas en las que me fijo
en el cabello los labios y los ojos y
las partes clásicas pero todo el mundo
tiene
tatuajes me dejaría estatuas
cuál es tu opinión polémica o bien creo
que la gente elogia muchos
de
ellos genial estado la gente le pone un
pedestal y hoteles que sea atractiva
ella es linda miren bien es tu mayor
bandera roja o
bien cuando alguien es grosero con los
camareros
cuál es la bandera roja de todos mentir
sin razón tener mucho ego si siempre
tienes la razón hay algo que está muy
mal leyes y tienes razón los mentirosos
malos en la comunicación no me gustan
los controladores que no asuman sus
errores definitivamente problemas de
compromiso el ego cuál es tu
personalidad favorita me gusta
divertirme me gusta hacer la mitad
tranquila te gusta salir pero no ser
demasiado me gusta si me gusta hacer la
parte de atrás de admitirse nuestro tipo
si a libia con el sello quería preguntar
cuál es tu lenguaje del amor
me gusta el contacto físico joshe porque
no me gusta que cualquiera me toque y
cuando pasa es los actos de servicio
cuando alguien se preocupa por ti y
hacen algo considerado eso es genial
bien alguien quiere quedarse pues hoy
siento una vibra de él yo también siento
una vibra de mar si él no quiere
quedarse sí
digamos me gusta alguien que sea más
extrovertido me gusta alguien que sepa
dirigir qué consejo le el ambiente y
todo eso creen que es gracioso no
es gracioso nos habría hecho reír tienes
razón es la verdad y mido si seguro es
intimidante me gustó que dijo que es
aventurero sí sí que viaja no podemos
votar por nosotras pueden votar por
ustedes bien
i
[Música]
las chicas eliminadas en esta ronda son
karting y cassidy
lo siento
[Risas]
ronda 3 1 a 1
cada una de las chicas tendrá una cita
con marx mientras las demás miran hola
soy ya son de hemorroides me atendré
helen kennedy un plazo igual hola soy un
poco tímida yo también soy tímido pero
no se meta lo primero que me gusto de ti
fue todo cuando gracias lo elegí porque
me da el control tocas la guitarra sí
pero más al piano el piano es difícil lo
eres bueno con los dedos creo que eso es
genial genial me gusta viajar me gusta
cuando dijiste que eras aventurero justo
eso en una persona ya estaba pensando en
tatuarme unae quieres si tiene que ser
en mi rostro aquí en un lugar
significativo si en el rostro genial eso
demuestra que eres una persona sino
metida me tatúo tu nombre si yo hablo en
mi rostro también si aquí que es lo que
más te daría vergüenza para mí sería
caerme en público puede sonar un poco
raro pero no me avergüenzo vaya si me
caigo solo me reiría
pero cuando te caes
6 y aún así te lindo anillo es un anillo
cromado puedo probar melo
así tienes los de los grandes si mis
dedos son algo gruesos me gusta ir al
gimnasio esta es una pregunta
interesante me gusta y es que ir al gym
tengo que ir pero a estas alturas es un
hábito me gusta sentirme adolorido es
como quien te puso el nombre te lo
pusiste to mars
quieres que lo hice fueran tus amigos
está bien de hecho no voy a decirte
porque es un secreto ahora tengo algo
que contarte soy de atlanta fui amor de
verdad vaya te gustó es que guarde nueva
york y todo eso no no no no nueva york
es la mejor ciudad del mundo los ángeles
me gusta mucho la moda esto es de
segunda mano es bonito me gusta la moda
es lo primero que ves puedo decir mucho
sobre alguien por lo que dices de mi
personalidad diez mil pero es divertido
y qué te dijo eso no lo sé la verdad es
todo el atuendo cuál es tu mayor temor
creo que estar solo bien es raro porque
soy una persona hogareña pero también
soy hogareño pero no quiero estar solo
te entiendo a mí me gusta estar en casa
y ver netflix pero con un novio a mi
lado eso es genial
adiós
un placer incluso nos vemos adiós
creo que jasmine es una verdad de verdad
enseguida te hizo preguntas si le
tendrás de y él estaba como estoy listo
para ti también se llevaba bien contigo
como si le pusieras nervioso como
alondra si ustedes hablaron de duda y de
segunda mano todo eso
ronda tres votación final
[Música]
revelación final estoy listo sientes que
hicieron una buena elección estás
nervioso un poco pero siento que la
elección debe ser buena 1 2 3
jasmine
que fue eso
hola hola cómo estás me esperaba se
esperaba bajo perfil baja por el bajo
perfil tú esperabas estar estaba
nerviosa tal vez el traje sí hizo algo
marzo de entregar eso es genial y
haremos que revelen a quienes
seleccionaste después de la segunda y
tercera ronda
vaya
para la segunda ronda tuve a yasmín el
en y ha sonado bien
para la última
tenía
a 10 min
es curioso
pensé que no te gustaba que no me habías
elegido estaba como me dirás quién te
dio tu nombre o si es una cita si
en el futuro si
estamos felices serán las damos pero sí
sería estupendo esta curiosa siempre y
cuando no pague debería esos niños
[Música]